[Music]
hey there
future michael it's today michael i
think you'd be proud to know that
i'm officially on sabbatical and i don't
know why i didn't do this sooner
in fact for the first time since kinkade
killed kurosawa
i'm starting to imagine a life without
bodyguarding
this really feels like a new beginning
psychological order finally darius isn't
posting my dreams
come on let's go
[Music]
what is he doing here i believe it's
pronounced
thank you for what uh for saving your
life again and again and again
you said baby get me michael brice
what no no no no no
i said baby i need help get anyone
but michael bryce what he
is the most annoying excuse me
i have 20 20 hearing i can hear you the
dead guys
can hear you how many times have you
nearly got me killed
not enough come on baby let's get out of
here before he starts the in-flight
safety demonstration
this reminds me of the spa back at the
hotel really
not at all okay let's blast this
[ __ ] whoa whoa whoa okay no you
go in there guns blazing they're gonna
get trigger happy inside then it's
bye-bye darius
he asks for me he needs me so we're
gonna do this
my way that means no killing
no guns and no blood boring is always
best
understood of course not
[Music]
jesus christ
what have you done yeah a little bit too
fresh i specifically said
no killing i'm not on sabbatical where
is your shirt
do you know what i just realized i'll
treat this as a
lovely road trip through italy and i'll
just pretend that you are still my
devoted husband
and you please you will be you will be
the human luggage
yes we are now on honeymoon first of all
it's a mission second of all and just so
we're clear i promised my therapist no
bodyguarding so i'm not protecting
either one mission
eyes on road babies need to be created
in a stimulating environment i must be
aroused
by sightseeing shopping fine dining
but we are officially on honeymoon
did she say fine dining let's not do
that guys let's just focus on the road
here oh
i got it no it's fine you guys just you
guys have had him
maybe feather the break a bit
i'll uh catch up with you later
who were you talking to that's a secret
i know your secrets you are so lonely
that you were talking to yourself
listen breeze do you really think i am
crazy
i think you're you're unusually
aggressive uh violent but in an
unpredictable way i would make a great
mother don't you think i think you're
yes
oh my god a child would be so lucky to
have you as its host
thank you priests thank you
it must be your powerful
asexuality that makes you such a good
listener
[Music]
you're going to tell us everything you
know
i'm not telling you a mother
you can electrocute him all day it'll
only make him angrier
i on the other hand will tell you
everything really
michael bryce was trying to put his past
behind him you need to forget
bodyguarding repeat after me no
bodyguarding
no
then he got pulled back in let go jesus
to protect this homicidal nut bags
wife what is he doing here i said get
anyone but
michael rice i believe it's pronounced
thank you
in four days all of europe was burned
they're planning a full-scale cyber
attack do not scoop this up
well we are definitely gonna screw this
up
i promised my therapist no bodyguarding
let's not do that guys let's just focus
i got it no it's fine you guys just you
guys have had him
maybe feather the break a bit i need you
to protect
us good time to have a baby now repeat
after me
i'm unlicensed i'm unlicensed that's
terrible
louder i'm unlicensed and i don't give
up
we need guns we need boats
we need them are you ready to get your
freak on
what that came out wrong not together
with us that also came out wrong now
let's go do what we do
and blow some things up
i would make a great mother tongue i
think your glasses thank you
it must be your powerful asexuality that
makes you such a good listener
we just acknowledge that not only are we
safe this really feels like a newbie
[Music]
you